c'est surtout autour de la ville
d'avdivka les Russes ont monté une
troisème vague d'assaut en engageant des
quantités de forces très
impressionnantes et en subissant des
pertes très impressionnantes jusqu'à
1000 soldats par jour tués selon les
renseignement britannique tués ou
blessés grave sans succès selon la ligne
officielle ukrainienne qui dit que les
forces ukrainiennes tiennent la ligne et
Contin continuent de tenir cette ville
presque entièrement détruite mais très
stratégique situé juste au nord de
donetk qui est contrôlé par les russes
depuis 2014 en vérité si on lit les
interviews que certains militaires
Ukrainiens donnent à la presse ces
derniers jours et notamment une tribune
écrit par og sov le Cineas qui avait été
emprisonné en Russie pendant quelques
années avant d'être libéré et qui a
dernièrement rejoint les forces armées
de l'Ukraine eux disent que la situation
est beaucoup plus difficile et que les
forces russes sont entrées dans la zone
industrielle au Sud-Est d'avdivka qui
était vraiment la forteresse ukrainienne
la seule partie de la ligne de front qui
n'avait pas bougé d'un cm depuis le
début de l'invasion à grande échelle en
février 2022 c'était la ligne de front
entre 2014 et
2023 maintenant visiblement les forces
russes sont dans cette zone industrielle
qui est très grande hein ils sont loin
de contrôler toute la zone mais le fait
qu'ils ont pénétré cette forteresse
ukrainienne selon de nombreux analystes
est très inquiétant pour l'avenir de la
défense ukrainienne de cette ville